[Musique]
you alors là on est passé à une image
assez classique
on a des jeunes sur leur téléphone
portable en train de pianoter pour
l'unification facebook in-stat g tout et
ça me gêne pas j'ai pas problème avec ça
là c'est un peu plus gênant quand même
quand le contexte de cette photo on est
face à la ronde de nuit de rembrandt on
et oryx museum à amsterdam est en phase
de cette oeuvre d'art et les enfants qui
sont sur un téléphone moi de mon époque
ça se passait pas comme ça alors on va
essayer de donner un contexte
supplémentaires la photo parce que là on
pourrait croire que les nouvelles
technologies sont une sorte de frein
entre ballard et nous en fait non ce que
ces jeunes sont en train de faire c'est
se renseigner sur la route de nuit via
l'application durix museum parce que ils
sont avec leurs professeurs et c'est
quelque chose que leur professeur leur
demande ça c'est le même groupe devant
une autre oeuvre voiliers sont super
studieux je vous dis pas n'importe quoi
alors là je me suis dit ok donc en fait
tu es en train de te rendre compte que
l'art peut avoir envers les nouvelles
technologies peuvent avoir un impact
bénéfique sur l'art et que en gros ça
peut changer nos appréhensions et notre
découverte de certaines oeuvres dans les
musées est ce cadeau exemple où il y en
a plein j'aime bien c'est au british
muséum en 2012 ils ont accueilli des
momies et les on passe au scanner et
grâce au scanner on a pu avoir plaint
d'avoir mation sur des momies des momies
qui tapait de 3000 ans avant
jésus-christ et genre on peut savoir par
exemple comment il était mort leur
métier est enfin plein d'informations et
le visiteur quand il rentrait dans
l'exposition la veine sorte de molette
et ils pouvaient naviguer à traire la
momie est arrivé en couches de scam donc
c'est assez fou
alors c'est pas mal ça serait bien
d'aller un peu plus loin est ce que la
nouvelle technologie peut pas avoir un
impact au lieu d'avoir un impact sur les
oeuvres dans le musée et comment on
interagit avec sur le musée lui-même
c'est quelque chose qui est fait aussi
il ya google qui a lancé le cultural
institute enrobage rentrer van gogh et
j'ai toutes les oeuvres de van gogh
donc ce qui n'est pas possible dans la
vie réelle parce qu'il faudrait aller
chercher un peu partout dans le monde
enfin une galère de fou et en plus je
peux visiter de manière virtuelle le van
gogh museum à la vous allez me dire
ouais mais visiter un musée
virtuellement c'est pas fou le mieux
savoir les oeuvres tout ok je conçois il
ya deux mois je partis au népal j'ai
rencontré bi djè bi djè il aimerait
beaucoup voir les oeuvres van gogh mais
il peut pas les âmes soeurs dame par
contre l'alcool sur internet et car
c'est sa connexion internet il peut
aller voir la nuit étoilée
cliquez sur la petite loupe bleus et hop
iran dans la nuit étoilée et en plus il
peut zoomer et on est dans une assez
haut définition des visions assez forte
pour que vous puissiez voir qu'en fait
ça a été peint directement sur la toile
et on voit même la toile de fond la voix
quoi ce cas c'est parce que c'est cool
donc la nouvelle technologie ça permet
plein plein de trucs ah pardon peut
zoomer encore plus au temps pour moi
on peut zoomer encore plus haut point on
voit carrément une cassure dans la
peinture et le coup de pinceau magistral
s'assure d'une technologie sap et logica
pixels ya un milliard de pixels sur
l'image en fait c'est un truc que vous
pourriez pas voir vous même devant
l'oeuvre
parce que vous pouvez pas être aussi
proche ou alors ça serait vraiment celle
où seraient personne ne fait ça donc la
nouvelle technologie permet à l'art
d'être un petit peu augmenté
un autre exemple que j'aime beaucoup
toujours sur gigapixels ça c'est là la
naissance de vénus de botticelli ça fait
trois mètres sur deux est juste au
niveau des yeux a parfois que jusqu'à 5
min claque là les yeux vous voyez ces
deux centimètres j'accueille regarder le
niveau de précision le reflet camille
botticelli c'est fou et c'est quelque
chose
encore une fois qu'il sera difficile à
voir pas difficile de voir sans les
mails dès que nous
e
le truc c'est que là on est sur comment
on à digitaliser les musées etc
ce serait bien sûr mais en fait le
prophète les musées ça m'intéresse pas
tant que ça moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est
plutôt les oeuvres qui sont dedans ça
serait cool si je pouvais de chez moi
directement de mon nouveau canapé j'ai
un nouveau canapé ça n'a rien à voir et
que la conférence
mais je le dis je la sais content
j'avais environ deux mois nouveau canapé
recevoir une oeuvre quoi et ça c'est
possible avec l'impression 3d opus sorti
du cercle lumineux normalement je crois
c'est ouais c'est la tête donc de amène
à matt et le british muséum a mis plein
de modèles sur sketch fab donc une
plateforme est pour sa part un modèle
imprimé avant 3d alors bon c'est pas
très réaliste et joue la corde mais on
est au tout début
1 et puis il ya des imprimantes 3d qui
imprime pierre anvers en métal enfin on
peut tout imaginer et la cfu voilà quand
même en termes de barrières que j'ai
j'ai cassé alors l'imprimante
l'impression 3d ça offre d'autres choses
par exemple ça c'est un projet d'une
artiste iranien qui s'appelle mollet
chine alliot marie est ce qu'elle a fait
c'est que elle a pris des oeuvres qui
sont fait détruire par l'état islamique
j'ai appris avec différentes photos à la
re créer des modèles 3d est les imprimés
à la mine clé usb dedans avec l'histoire
de l'oeuvre donc là on a dollar qui qui
est conservée d'une manière inégalable
certains musées ça peut ça peut détruire
ça peut brûler une information digitale
misant plus sur l'internet pour le coup
ça va être dur à décrire
alors g7
face à moi sur mon canapé je cette
oeuvre comment je fais parce que là on
terme voilà les barrières qui avait
entre l'oeuvre et moi j'ai pas mal
détruit déjà avec la nouvelle
technologie est là je les observe
c'est peut-être en fait c'est peut-être
juste je la perception
peut-être que les nouvelles technologies
et pourrait avoir un impact sur la
perception way est le fond ça c'est un
projet de david eagleman c'est une veste
qui transforme tous les sons extérieurs
en vibration sur le corps c'est à dire
que en gros une symphonie beethoven vous
pouvez l'entendre mais vous pouvez aussi
la sentir ça c'est fou
c'est incroyable donc là en gros les
nouvelles technologies changent
carrément notre manière de percevoir
l'art et donne une autre dimension en
fait
alors ok bon alors là ça va être dur
d'aller un peu plus loin
du coup je veux être allé au coeur de la
création je vais peut-être me mettre du
côté du créateur est ce que les
nouvelles technologies peuvent m'aider à
créer oui oui sinon je poserai pas la
question
c'est une question rhétorique oui elles
le peuvent et je montrais un projet un
projet qui s'appelle wind map
c'est un projet artistique de fernanda
viegas et matthew winter bergues
voilà et en gros ils ont pris des
données devant aux états unis et les ont
formalisé pour créer une carte
interactive vous voyez que ça bouge rsa
convoiterait pas si on voit tout au fond
en gros ça ça bouge en temps réel avec
les courants devants aux états unis
c'est un projet artistique donc là la
nouvelle technologie
les nouvelles technologies ont été un
outil ok donc lâché en train de rendre
compte qu'en fait je pourrais être chez
moi je pourrais créer de l'art et je
pourrais le rendre y perd facilement
accessibles aux chantiers etc
je suis peut-être à deux doigts de
devenir riche en fait là si je trouve un
moyen de créer de l'art assez facilement
en fait il faudrait que j'appuie sur un
bouton et que l'art sort tout seul
aaron aaron c'est un peintre il peint
depuis 1970 et aussi c'est une
intelligence artificielle
il a été conçu par harold cohen qui
explique que mais en fait ce genre de
projet en projet artistique c'est un peu
comme un enfant on balance dans la vie
et ont gardé une connexion avec et
explique qu'il a perdu sa connexion avec
aaron parce que aaron est devenu trop
indépendant le flippant mais il n'ya pas
qu'eux
pictural on peut imaginer d'autres types
d'art ça c'est mes l'omx donc levé
l'intelligence artificielle qui fait du
son voilà c'est une bonne musique
d'ascenseur sapa les daft punk mais
c'est un bon début mais d'amendé et là
je me suis dit ok bon bah voilà
oui je vais je mettre son canapé je vais
être votre échange riche en fait pas du
tout pas du tout un truc que j'ai
carrément zappé rejoint jeu vous allez
comprendre
en jouant un jeu qui s'appelle art ou
par jeu vous montrer des images et vous
me dites si ces deux là ou pas là ok
mais je vais jouer vraiment le jeu
d'accord on va faire un essai alors si
c'est de l'art ouais si c'est pas de la
whey hockey ouais la joconde banshee
nénuphars monnaies ok ah non pardon non
ça c'est du lard ça c'est du là désolé
excusez moi l'homme qui marche i a
cometti à quai et des gens pour qui suis
là c'est plus problématique et les gens
pour qui c'est plus problématique
alors des fois il ya des sourcils qui se
feront danser je vous donnais un petit
peu le contexte autour de cette oeuvre
donc c'est la fontaine de marcel duchamp
en fait il ya la société des artistes
anonymes de new york en 1917 dont marcel
duchamp est un monde directeur qui
décide de faire une exposition
il faut une exposition ils disent on
accepte n'importe quelle oeuvre on en
refuse aucune sous des prétextes
esthétique marcel duchamp des chouettes
je me faire une fausse identité j'ai
envoyé un urinoir inversée donc il se
fait appeler air motte ici 1917 il
envoie l'urinoir et l'urinoir est refusé
scandale
il démissionne scandale dans la presse
et tout et n'importe quoi et est pour
beaucoup de ses contemporains
c'est dollar parce que il prend un objet
il lui enlève sa fonctions usuelles et
repenser totalement le blay
des gens qui fronce les sourcils parfois
c'est parce qu'en fait il ya zéro
technique il ya juste 0 technique en
urinoir on renverse on met rmat 917
caylar ouais ouais
désolé il ya zéro technique alors que
dans tout ce qu'on a vu avant il y en
avait et mon point là c'est vous dire
que la chanson de mélo mix ou les
peintures café aaron c'est pas parce
qu'il ya de la technique que c'est de
l'art en fête
c'est peut-être pour ça que personne ne
va acheter mais mes oeuvres que mes
oeuvres d'art et que je vais finir
pauvres et pour ça parce que derrière
l'art et al'intention ya pas que
l'intention il ya il peut y avoir aussi
d'autres choses par exemple il ya le
fait que ce soit reconnu par ses pairs
donc le fait que les autres
reconnaissent que ce soit là il ya aussi
parfois l'artiste qui a une sensibilité
une compréhension tel de son époque
qu'il arrive à la surpasser par exemple
giacometti bas c'est une des premières
fois qu'on jouait de cette manière là
avec un socle et ça allait à l'encontre
des règles de l'académie monnaie avec il
peignait pas juste et des nénuphars
manière réaliste mais et peignez son
impression donc c'est l'impressionnisme
et c'est la joconde leonardo domenici
d'habitude quand on peignait un sujet il
regardait à gauche ou à droite mais très
rarement l'observateur tout ça c'est
nouveau c'est une manière de surpasser
c'est important que vous ayez les
contextes de ses oeuvres c'est comme ça
qu'on puisse avancer là ou pas là que si
je vous avais montré sa classe est plus
dur là là c'est plus dur à savoir quelle
est l'intention derrière et c'est alors
que c'est radicalement différent c'est à
gauche ou à droite que celle l'arraché
plus nancy je sais en fait c'est moi qui
ai fait la pause ok à gauche c'est une
oeuvre du street art 6 tu auras qui est
connu dans le monde entier
chez les sept artistes et qui a la
volonté de réintégrer les animaux dans
la jungle urbaine et à droite c'est
david hockey un robot alors il david il
a l'air vachement loin de nous n'est pas
du tout la même forme enfin j'espère
pour vous et là pas du tout une forme
humaine quoi mais on peut imaginer et ça
va arriver ça arrive déjà des
intelligences artificielles qui ont une
forme très proche de la nôtre qui ont
des émotions et qui ont une conscience
aussi du coup je voulais vous laisser
avec une dernière idée une dernière
question
je m
devant mon nouveau canapé jamais dit
qu'ils étaient neuf le ludique était
nouveau mais jugez pas
donc j'en ai dans mon nouveau canapé
avec mon robot et imaginons imaginons
que mon robot y voit le canapé pas
seulement comme un objet avec la
fonction la fonction canapé qui est de
s'asseoir dessus ni seulement comme la
fonction une fonction dérivés qui serait
de pouvoir mettre son linge sale dessus
ou le déplacer pour bloquer la porte que
sage non imaginons que mon robot il voit
ce canapé
juste comme un canapé qu'il détaille sa
fonction et qu' il décide de prendre du
ketchup de mètres du ketchup dessus mais
pourquoi tu fais ça c'est hyper chaud
bouillant et qui me disent je sais pas
je trouve qu'il est qu'il est mieux
comme ça chauffe qui les plus beaux
jours qui les plus parfaits
bah là ça a toujours été le propre de
l'homme
alors si un robot simon robot fait ça un
jour
est-ce que je peux pas l'appeler humain
c'est la question je me pose et ces
questions je vous pose merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]